I proceeded there for after a voyage of
fifty days came to the countries of the
Bosch naka a people who have mouths like
those of dogs this is a vile race they
have no religion neither that of the the
Hindus nor any other they live in houses
made of reeds upon the seashore
the trees are those of the banana the
for fall and the betel nut the men are
of the same form as ourselves except
that the mouths are like those of dogs
but the women have mouths like many
other folks the men go naked without the
least covering whatsoever only one among
them I saw who put his Marilia into a
painted hollow Reed which was hung to
his belly
the women cover themselves with the
leaves of trees one who had much
intercourse with them told me that they
copulate like beasts without the least
concealment
the man will have 30 or more wives but
adultery is not committed should anyone
however be convicted of this crime this
punishment is to be hanged until he's
dead until he brings either a friend or
slave who is willing to be hanged for
him he may then go free the sentence for
the woman is that the king shall command
all his servants to trample upon her one
after another till she dies she is then
thrown into the sea the women resists
the men to a degree beyond their nature
but the men from their baseness of
character and fear about the women will
not allow any one of the merchants to
proceed on the sea in front of their
houses they will merely consult and
trade with them carrying their fresh
water on the backs of elephants when we
put into their port their king came to
us riding on an elephant upon which
there was something like a saddle cloth
made of skin the king himself was
dressed in goat skin the hairy part of
which he turned outwards upon his head
was a turban of colored silk and in his
hand a short silver spear with him was a
number of his relations riding upon
elephants and using a language which no
one could understand unless he had been
sometime among them we sent him the
usual present for every ship putting
into any port of India's expected to
send a present to the magistrate of the
place now these people buy and receive
as presents she elephants over which
they put saddle cloth but do not
completely clothe them but any ship not
giving them their present they will so
work upon them with their magic that the
sea will rise upon it and it will perish
or they will return upon and injure it
within left this place and in 50 days
arrived at the island of Java the place
from which the incense of Java receives
its name
and all the men and women of that aisle
have hounds heads and they'd be kept
Kanaka phallus and they'd be full
reasonable and of good understanding
saved that they worship an ox for their
God and also every one of them Bharath
an ox of gold or silver in his forehead
in token that they love well their God
and they go all naked save a little
clout that they cover with their knees
and their members they'd be great folk
and well fighting and they have a great
Taj that covers all the body with a
spear in their hand to fight with and if
they take any man in battle anon they
eat him
the king of that Isle is full rich and
full mighty and right devout after his
law and he hath about his neck
three hundred pearls orient good and
great and knotted and in manner as we
say our Ave Marias counting the
Paternoster 's right so this king says
every day devoutly three hundred prayers
to his God before he eats and he beareth
also about his NECA a ruby orient noble
and fine that is a fruit of length and
five fingers large and when they choose
their king they take him that Ruby to
bear in his hand and so they lead him
riding all about the city and from
thence forward they all are obedient to
him and that Ruby he shall bear always
about his neck for if he had not that
Ruby upon him men would not hold him
King the great Chan of Caffe hath
greatly coveted that ruby but he might
never have it for war nor for any manner
of goods this King is so rightful and of
equity in his domains that men may go
calmly throughout all his country and
bear with them what they list in the
knowledge that no man shall be hardy to
rob them and if he were the king would
be notified on on
from this land men go to another island
that is clipped Scylla and it is well
800 miles about and that land is full of
much waste for his full of serpents of
dragons and of copper drills that no man
dwell their anger mundane is a very
large island the people are without a
king and are idolaters and no better
than the wild beasts and I assure you
all the men of this island of Angermann
I have heads like dogs and teeth and
eyes like wise in fact in the face
they're all just like big Mastiff dogs
they have a quantity of spices but they
are a most cruel generation and eat
everybody that they can catch if not of
their own race they live on flesh and
rice and milk and have fruits different
from any of us now that I've told you
about this race of people as indeed it
was highly proper to do in this book
I'll go on to tell you about an island
called
saven as you shall hear
[Music]
you